Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bird.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 25th,
2013 how's it going?
Um,
I'm still in Boston by,
my record is still fucked up so just bear with me.
There's can be one more week,
but I promise I plugged in my laptop so they won't be the fan sound this week.
At least I got rid of that.
Right.
It's a,
it's snowing out here.
I'm sitting in a hotel room.
I got the Oscars on in the background now cause I want him watch him.
Nia was just watching him.
I told you to go downstairs to the bar.
Well I do this.
Um,
I'd like to have her on the podcast,
but it's going to sound like shit.
Sounds like shit with one person.
Forget about too.
Um,
[inaudible] I dunno,
I dunno.
I just,
you know,
I was all psyched to do this stupid podcast and I had the sound down on the TV
and I saw Barbara Streisand and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Is she singing?
I know sheet notoriously has stage fright.
She doesn't like to do it.
So I turned it on and she was singing that song memories,
which is a whose kitten home.
It's one of the most depressing fucking songs you ever going to listen to.
Really just affected my mood.
MMM.
Barbara,
if you're listening to this,
could you please stop singing that fucking song?
Mammaries where we all used to be young.
A lot of our dreams didn't happen and now we're gone.
A die.
Right?
I fucking do not like sad songs like that.
I don't mind individual pain.
Oh,
speak in a songs.
Uh,
I read,
you know,
I've known about that Dude Bruno Mars for a while and I just,
I listened to a little bit of his ship,
but you know,
I'm an old man.
I can't relate to somebody singing about the prime of their life.
I mean,
I lived through the prime of my life,
at least I hope I did well.
Maybe I hope I didn't,
which means we get better at some point.
And that Barbara Streisand wouldn't be fucking bumming me out.
Their goddamn depressing songs.
What's it knowing?
She always sings it with the most sparkly fucking dress on.
Yeah.
They should rename that song.
Put a gun in your mouth.
Oh Jesus.
Look how old Richard Gere is now.
It's just,
I don't need this.
He just told me fucking Ernest Borgnine died,
which I didn't even know.
Half the people who are dying made movies when I was a kid now,
which means that fucking grim reaper a sickle is right on my ass.
I don't need to see that.
Somebody who did something on Iti just died or some guy who made the fucking
shark fin and jaws died.
Well I guess maybe I do.
That guy should get you should get is a,
he should get his due.
Right.
Did you guys hear me typing here?
I just remember I needed to talk about something that that guy should get his
due without fuck.
You know,
without a doubt.
But I mean I,
I don't,
I just find it really depressing,
you know,
I don't know.
Anyways,
the hell
am I talking about?
I'm,
I'm hearing Boston and uh,
oh,
this is going to be a rough one.
People,
this just gotta to be a rough one.
Once again,
once again talking into my fucking laptop.
This is bizarre to me.
Um,
a lot of my comfort zone there.
There I said it,
you know,
I haven't watched all the Oscars did they did,
did they do that stupid moment they do every year where they go movies?
Yeah.
They allow us to dream bad Alice,
to look at life differently.
They allow us to see a future where things are bad tie.
They allow us not to have our balls sticking to our legs in the summertime.
If you don't have air conditioning,
it's great to go in the theater.
MMM.
I actually didn't see a lot of the movies this year.
Jesus look at the fucking ass on her.
Uh,
anybody else?
Notice Nicole Kidman did too many of those,
those shoulders shrug exercises with the fuck was going on with her.
She doesn't wear a cornerback just in the neck though.
Is that Palladia Palladia he's like,
ah,
that's one good thing that we got out of the acquisition,
didn't we?
As we got that little [inaudible] stretcher rack there,
how fucked up was the inquisition?
Huh?
Bunch of people going around torture.
And your,
you say that you believed in the bearded baby,
you know,
is it any wonder why I left that religion?
Ah,
who's kitten home?
I didn't want to get up there that fucking early.
Um,
anyways,
I had,
I had a huge,
huge week before I really get going here.
I want to thank everybody who,
uh,
came out to the Patrice O'Neal benefit on Tuesday night.
Uh,
it was an unbelievable success and it was so great to finally send,
send them off the right way and I got to tell you,
everybody on the show was hilarious and I really felt that people stepped it up
and we're just going above and beyond.
Um,
um,
like Keith Robinson was the funniest I've ever seen him calling Quinn Jim
Norton,
Dave Attell,
everybody crushed.
Ian Edwards was,
was great just because,
uh,
you know,
he does a lot of writing and I think not enough people know what a phenomenal
comedian he is.
A rich foss hosted Bobby Kelly jumped on the grenade,
came out first.
We'll still vets.
Who else did I miss?
Somebody in there.
I probably missed somebody and they're going to get upset.
But,
um,
it was such a success.
Um,
I,
I'm not gonna I,
I hope that we get to do it again cause it was great to see all those guys and
everybody of course was backstage trash and everyone,
some people wore suits,
other people didn't.
So immediately there was a Hatfield's and Mccoy's going on in the green room.
So everybody was getting trashed.
Norton took a nice pounding,
poor guy,
got himself in shape.
He thinks he's looking good,
but evidently he bought a suit when he was a little more pudgy or so.
Everyone was trashed him about that.
And,
uh,
you know,
I caught some shit from my big head,
the usual,
the usual sort of,
oh,
the tit for tat that went on backstage.
But,
um,
I want to thank everybody who came out.
Um,
it,
it really was an awesome night and,
uh,
I feel very thankful that all you guys who buy tickets came out and see people
about the posters and that type of thing.
And I'm really hoping that we can do it again at some point.
I have no idea when next year,
two years.
I have no idea.
But it was too fun to not at least consider maybe doing it again.
All right,
so they go all right.
Back to the podcast here.
I've already started this thing a couple of times.
I forget if I already brought this up,
but uh,
Tom Papa has joined the wonderful world of all things,
comedy podcast network that I started without magical.
Um,
he's going to be taping a new standup special and this free tickets available if
you're in the New York area,
he's going to be at the,
uh,
the Skirball.
Did I already do this?
I'd probably already did,
but I'm going to do it again.
Is that this curve ball on March 7th?
We'll put the link up there.
I don't remember.
Did I already do it?
I probably already did it.
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
plowing.
Oh,
it's talking about singers.
So Bruno Mars was this guy that,
you know,
I knew he was a talented kid or whatever,
but like I said,
you know,
a lot of his songs,
it was spot being young and going out and partying.
And that whole being in your 20s and that type of thing.
And uh,
you know,
but old bastard,
I mean,
I think I'm closer to Neil Young's age that I am Bruno Mars.
But,
uh,
I dunno what I was doing.
I was clicking and going through the Internet and I saw him sing on that show,
the voice,
uh,
which had I known it was the voice,
I wouldn't have watched it cause I don't like that show.
And like how they all sit there with it fucking backs to the singer and they're
lazy boys and then they hit the button and they turn around and that's supposed
to be like exciting for me as the viewer,
you know,
like my life is that sad and pathetic.
Not Saying it's not sad and pathetic to get,
you know,
you got to do more than spin around in a fucking lazy boy to get me going.
All right.
But anyways,
he goes on that show,
sang this song when I was your man.
Absolutely fucking crushes it.
Watched it like 10 times.
So this whole week I'm up at the,
uh,
the Wilbur theater and I'm working with,
the sensation Joe to Rosa.
And I keep telling him about it and it keeps breaking my balls saying that I
like this fucking teen idol and all that type of thing.
And I just wouldn't let it up.
And I finally made him sit down and watch it last night when we were hammered,
he got through it and then I took an unbelievable pounding,
but from him and Nia that actually like it.
But you know what?
I stand by it.
I don't give a shit.
If you guys give me a rough,
do you know what I was excited about is the fact that there's,
does somebody young out there who actually just go out there with a piano player
and just sing?
You know,
those Djs that I,
I don't,
you know,
I've already talked about that on Conan.
I don't know.
I don't fucking get what's going on there.
You know,
fucking Kanye West guy does a whole song,
use a whole album using auto tune.
He can't even sing.
And even worse,
he goes out on fucking tour
and people are paid tickets to watch your guys single care fucking sing without
the cigarettes who like this iron lung or some shit and they're paying like 100
bucks to sit in the front row to watch subject,
can't even fucking sing.
It was just,
you know,
it made me feel good to see somebody just come out there and absolutely fucking
crush it like that.
So,
um,
I've been joking with me as like,
I got to go see this dude life
and I have to bring you because it's going to be a bunch of fucking teenage
girls and then my old ass is going to be standing there.
I've got to get arrested.
But uh,
I dunno.
So that was a great thing to wow.
It's a great thing to see.
You know,
when you get old,
what happens is,
is shit changes and because you're grumpy,
you don't think anything's better.
Is this too fucking loud?
Am I blowing myself out here?
I said,
Goddamn heart attack here in the mixer.
Um,
now when you get old like shit,
change assumption changes for the better,
you know,
hair transplants are way better.
Some medicine is better,
but a lot of other shits suffers.
Cars all look the same.
I guess they're better as far as the handling and safety and Shit,
but you know,
okay,
sub shit was better.
People could send back in the day.
So it's nice to see somebody that can,
all right,
Jesus Christ,
you'd think I'm drunk here.
That's actually two positive things I had said in a row that never happens on
this podcast.
MMM.
All right.
You know what I'm,
I'm actually upset that I missed and happy that I missed was a women fighting in
the UFC.
Okay.
I just,
there's just something,
there's just something so wrong about that,
you know,
to be just sitting there taking fucking kicks to your womb.
Okay.
I mean,
you're,
you're where you're supposed to be better than that.
It's supposed to be able to solve your fucking problems,
you know,
by by,
I dunno,
pulling each other's hair.
I don't want to see some girl take a kick to her titties and ground and
empowered and they're pretty faces that there really is to,
I dunno,
I don't want to get used to seeing that.
You know,
it's kind of like when you first start watching porn,
second girl bends over doggy style.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
that's,
you know,
it's incredible.
Then after wild doesn't do anything for you,
you got to go to the next level.
I didn't want to do that with fighting.
I want to keep it like,
you know,
I can watch two guys beat the shit out of each other.
I really don't want to say to women kicked the shit out of each other.
So,
but on the other side,
I think it's a great thing
that women can fight like that.
I actually have a solution.
I might bring this up to rogue and if I,
if I get to do his podcast,
um,
or if I ever bring them on this one,
if I stop being so fucking lazy and actually have a guest every once in a while,
uh,
I have a solution.
I think that those were the women or the UFC rather than fighting each other.
They should fight a convicted rapist.
Right.
Just hear me out.
You take them out of out of the
and they don't know.
They don't know.
Wait.
Well that's weird.
Is that too much?
If they have to write this,
doesn't know that he's got to have a pay per view fight that he's going to be
involved in it.
Um,
I would ever give the rape as a fighting chance.
Here's a deal.
You go in there,
you fight the broad and I,
if you,
if,
if she wins,
everyone's going to be happy.
If the rapist wins,
then what?
He gets to go free.
He can't let them go.
What does he get?
A couple of cartons of cigarettes.
Did you know how fucking,
how much of an asshole you'd have to be to route for the rapist?
Cause that's the fucked up thing.
Like Vegas would be then taking odds.
So at some point
they would have to make just,
you know,
cause money.
Vegas always wants money on both sides of the ball.
They would have to make it sell fucking enticing that he'd have to bet the
rapist just so they could offset everybody who doesn't want to bet on our,
on a rapist,
right?
Oh No.
I'll take it back to you on that one.
I'll have to work that one out.
As far as how that would work out.
Did Anybody Watch it?
Can you send me some emails?
Cause I,
I really don't want to see that.
I,
I've seen it in boxing a couple of times and some girls just sort of jab the
other,
thrown on us,
stiff jabs and just punches the girl.
Right.
And one of her breasts,
and this is just something wrong about it.
You know,
a low blow.
She had a baby man,
you know,
you can't,
it's just,
I dunno,
it was funny.
Some women actually get mad at them with their,
their constant quest to be doing everything that men do and never really
stepping back to consider whether what we're doing is stupid or not.
They just want to fucking do everything that we're doing so they could feel like
that they are,
they are free.
Uh,
Charlie's Styron.
What do you think about that haircut at Wayne Gretzky in 1988,
she should be up there fucking accepting the heart trophy.
I,
you know,
it's funny
though,
when she was on the,
uh,
the red carpet,
she said,
uh,
they asked her about her haircut and she said the same thing.
Every check says that has short hair.
She goes,
oh my God.
It's so freeing.
It's just,
it's just every woman should do it.
And I'm thinking like,
no,
they shouldn't.
For my own selfish reasons,
you know,
you don't need to get the EFL haircut that young and your life.
That's really what that is.
That base you and you get that haircut.
You're basically saying,
you know,
I don't care if my husband wants to fuck me or not.
We're,
we're legally bound here.
I got enough years in.
By all means go fuck somebody else.
I really don't care.
Uh,
uh,
oh my God.
You know,
something like,
I've noticed that was like in marriage,
is that that's a moment in the marriage when the woman went,
I'm sure some people can send me some emails when your wife cuts off all of
beautiful hair.
All right.
Got It.
So easy.
I just wash and go,
you know?
Right.
Then when a woman gets a haircut that short,
it's like doggy style becomes a really weird position,
you know,
depending on their hair color,
they can all of a sudden look like,
what are your friends?
You know?
All right,
I'm really going off from the women here.
I'm really putting you guys in a box.
No Pun intended.
All right?
I don't think you should fight in the UFC unless you're fighting rapists.
Uh,
uh,
I don't think that you should get the,
Mabel haircut until you're,
I dunno.
That should be the menopause haircut,
hot flashes.
I can't have my teenage hair anymore.
It's making my brow sweaty.
I think that that's when you should cut it off.
[inaudible]
they always do.
They always,
I don't know.
It doesn't always have to still fucking tease it in some way.
It's like,
why don't you just,
just,
just part it on the fucking side.
If you just going to go out and go out and get like a Steve Carell haircut,
then you should call it like him.
Seek for all.
That's a bad,
that's a bad reference.
Who has just a club,
a George Clooney.
You know Jesus Bill.
I get judged and enough people here or what?
Yeah,
I am.
What are you gonna do about it?
All right.
Clicking here on,
Hey,
I know this is making a ton of noise.
I don't know what to tell you.
I got some advertising here I got to read.
All right everybody.
Where is it?
Where is it legal?
Zobe everybody
legal zoom.
Are you waiting for the perfect time to start your dream business?
Well,
it's right now.
Legal Zoom,
the official sponsor of the National Starch Your Business Month once you to get
started right now.
Uh,
whether you're setting up at Ellis LLC,
an s Corp Sole Proprietorship or a nonprofit legal zoom takes care of you from
start to finish.
They're award winning service was developed by the best legal minds in the
country.
Every business gets personalized attention.
That's why over 90% of legal zoom customers would recommend this service to
their family.
You'll be in good company,
three dozen companies on the Inc,
I guess that's inc 500 list.
We're started through legal zoom.
MMM
Wow,
man.
It's actually 36 of them.
For those of you can't add,
um,
it's national starch your business months to start your business
right@legalzoom.com.
Legalzoom is not a law firm and provides self-help services at your specific
direction.
So if you need help,
ask them.
But there's so much more now.
Every LLC and incorporation package includes easy to use business accounting
software,
uh,
$269 value,
absolutely free.
Be sure to enter bur bur are in the referral box at checkout.
Start Your Business,
protect your family,
and safeguard your assets at legal zoom today.
All right,
and after you started your business,
oh shit.
Quintin Tarantino won an Oscar.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Good Fam.
That's the original screenplay.
He looks good too.
It's got a leather tie their hands.
He said,
I have something in there that he's a maverick.
Uh,
that makes me happy.
Good for him.
Um,
all right.
stamps.com everybody,
uh,
do you want to do everything you can do at the post office and the safety of
your own home safety of her own apartment,
a man,
your little tent city,
you stamp.com with stamps.com everything you would do at the post office you can
do right from your own desk.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter package using your own computer
or printer stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale.
Calculates the exact postage you need for any class of male.
You'll never have to go to the post office again or even lease one of those
expensive postage meters.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs.
I never have a problem.
It's made my life a lot easier and I'm so dumb if I can figure it out.
So can you right now use my last name.
Burpee you are are for a special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and up to $55 free
postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible].
That was pretty good rate.
I got to admit I was reading that and watching a very excited Quintin Tarantino.
Sorry,
I leaned back.
Fuck,
I forget the microphone's right here.
Oh,
it's going to be so uneven.
Um,
the hell are we?
Oh,
Jesus.
I'm sorry guys.
This is,
this is even from me.
This is a level of unprofessionalism,
um,
that I mentioned Tom Papa,
yet,
you know,
suck today.
Aside from the fact that it was doing that and knowing,
not raining,
not snowing and blowing horizontally right in your face.
I really do not miss the winter,
by the way.
I do not miss this shit at all.
I'm going to go right back out to Los Angeles and breathe in that Nice warm smog
that I've really gotten accustomed to.
MMM.
When we got here,
I,
you know,
the Bruins are on today and I have the,
uh,
I have the,
whatever the center ice package,
whatever you call it,
on my computer.
And,
but because it was a local game,
it's blacked out on my computer and I'm in a hotel and they don't have ness.
And so I didn't get to watch it,
but I did see the clip of Aza Danal Charles Three ThreeSixty
backhand goal,
you know,
let's see.
John Scott do that.
Buffalo fans.
Hey,
buffalo fence.
Did you see,
did you see what's his face said?
John Scott shouldn't even be in the league.
I've literally sound like a school girl.
Even Jeremy Rolnick does it like,
um,
uh,
I can't wait till we played with the sabers again and I can't wait till we play
the stupid Canadians.
You know what I love about the Canadians is they're thrilled trying to walk
around like they're the kings of the league.
I mean,
last time the Canadians won a Stanley Cup.
White people loved Oj Simpson.
Okay.
White people last time they want it.
It was a year before white people were like,
oh my God,
oh Jay is a monster.
You know,
and black people too,
but only amongst themselves.
They're not allowed to admit it to white people.
That's how long it's been.
And they still walk around.
Oh,
it's so embarrassing when you go up to this stupid,
this stadium there,
right as you go in all they got all their Stanley Cups,
you know,
which I'm sure is a great idea when they built the place,
cause they probably thought there's no fucking way we're going to go on,
uh,
you know,
decade upon decade drought here because then I went in it this year,
they're not,
and if,
you know,
if they want it this year,
mmm.
I'm actually going to lobby now,
update if they straight up when I don't give a fuck.
But if I've,
I haven't watched too many of the games,
but if they're playing that trap defense,
like I heard,
mmm.
Like that kid Canadians Rangers game where the,
the coach of the ranger said it was one of the worst hockey games he's ever
seen.
Just completely boring.
I don't understand for the life of me why the Nhl just doesn't make that an
illegal defense.
If basketball,
the NBA is smart enough to be like,
listen guys,
a too big and too fast,
you've come up with the defense.
That is just far too effective.
It's so cutting down the scoring.
It's affecting the entertainment value of the product.
That's an illegal defense.
You can't do it anymore.
I don't know why they just haven't made the fucking thing illegal.
It's the worst.
It's the fucking worst.
All you do is just sit there watching the other team just dumps it in the whole
game,
you know?
And the other team just sits there waiting for you to make a mistake.
It's,
it's literally,
it's like,
I don't know what it's like watching.
It's,
I can't even say a pitcher's duel cause a pitcher's duel is exciting watching.
If they're mowing people down,
there's still great plays.
Be it made like exciting stops in the field.
If you know somebody got a no hitter going,
that can be exciting.
No scoring and hockey,
I can't even say no scoring it.
No rush is on the net.
You know,
I think that basic,
you know,
the forward should all be required.
I mean I guess,
you know,
I guess I don't,
the trap is there they are for checking.
It's just too,
it's too fucking effective.
I don't know who came up with it but is perfect.
I was actually,
I'll give you a link to it for you guys.
The one hockey fans,
if you watch it,
it's really phenomenal.
So,
uh,
it's just take two people just can't,
I was watching one youtube video and the guy was saying he had a system that
could beat it,
but I don't think he does.
There are so many in the NHL would be doing it.
You know what I like to do people,
I like to have a microphone that I lean away from talking about the most obscure
of the top four sports and breaking down the defenses cause I feel that that's
going to be,
that's to be interesting for the feds.
Uh,
all right,
let's,
let's get,
let me at least for the love of God get to a goddamn letter here.
Uh,
this is from Mexico.
All Law on Bray.
Sorry.
Now I'm,
first of all,
I'm a huge fan of yours from Mexico.
If I was a newscaster,
I would've been,
first of all,
I'm a huge fan of yours from Mexico.
Um,
I love you.
Stand up.
I love when you are at cone up.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] thanks for,
I'll keep it up.
Thank you.
All right.
That was it.
Oh,
that was the whole letter.
I'm sorry.
I love you.
Stand up.
I love when you are at Conan and recently,
I love the boots.
You are rocking at your latest appearance.
So if possible,
could you share what brand,
what brand are those are the fuck are they?
You know what?
I have him.
Hang on a second.
I'll go get them.
I'll go get them for you.
Oh my God.
What a podcast.
Just amazing.
They are
with the shoes.
I gotta be honest with you.
Mi Amigo from Mexico.
Um,
I got these when I was in Stockholm,
Sweden.
I had to get something.
They are a Christ.
My fucking eyes are going.
I tell you that.
I tell you that my fucking eyesight's going,
you know,
piss me off is always hanging out with the ob from the opiate.
Then he show and he asked me one day,
he goes,
dude,
you have you or your eyes starting to go yet I got no,
my eyes are fine.
He goes,
he's like,
they will broke.
They,
well,
he's always doing that shit.
You shoulder hurt.
No,
no it doesn't,
but hey wait,
we wait.
You wait.
It's gonna.
And I'm like,
why does he think that all of his ailments are going to hit me?
It's not an age thing.
It's how you lived your life.
You know we have two totally different bodies.
Why would you say that to me?
And the fucking son of a bitch was right about my eyes,
wasn't right about the shoulders.
All right.
They're called a
Rizzo.
See the Rizzo or piss off?
I think it's Rizzo.
Rizz.
Oh,
I got him in Sweden though a couple of years ago and God knows they probably
stopped making them because that's what they do,
right?
They start making clothes.
Everybody loves him and then they get rid of him.
They got to get some new ones.
Yeah,
these are,
you know what?
That's the sound of an almost empty 10 of bootleg.
Bootleg fucking eminence stinks to suck any wrong with them.
I can't stop eating it,
but they're disgusting.
Totally ripped off.
M.
And.
M's,
they look just like them except they don't have the [inaudible].
All right.
This is from Ireland,
Ireland in the new world.
Order dare below for a bet,
a huge fan of your podcast for years now and think your advice is pretty fucking
great and thank you.
In fact,
listening to one of your podcasts,
help me leave a shitty toxic relationship.
Look at this.
Oh Billy red faced south and people out and I've been lucky enough to meet a
fantastic woman since.
Hey Buddy,
it couldn't be more happy for you.
Go to been happier for you anyways,
he says,
enough blowing smoke up your arse.
I love when people do that.
I didn't ask you to do it and I helped you out with the most important thing in
your life,
so go fuck yourself.
Anyways,
he said,
I'm from Ireland and that country is pretty much owned by the European banks now
and no longer a sovereign state essentially was taken down,
eat economically,
economically,
and everyone isn't dead.
Now I live in Britain and now they are voting on having secret courts and all
kinds of terrifying or welly and shit
secret courts.
Oh my God.
So it does seem we're skipping towards the new world order.
My question is on population reduction.
How do you think the new world order are going to going to take us all out?
Also,
when you say you understand why they want to do this,
what about the fact that they want
to turn who's left into slaves?
Uh,
I don't condone it,
but I mean that is pretty much,
uh,
the history of human beings.
You know,
I mean,
we're all unbelievably lucky to living right now as free people,
you know,
cause we really think about yourself.
What do you know?
What are you bringing to the table?
You know,
I don't know.
I can't talk for you,
but I'm certainly not royalty.
I haven't invented anything.
Uh,
so why shouldn't I be out there picking up heavy shipped for smart people?
That's probably one of the dumbest things I ever said,
but I,
I get,
I don't know,
I just,
I don't have any faith in human beings.
I just think that,
uh,
there's a select few
okay.
That are raw decent,
and I'm not including myself when I say that.
And I just don't feel that I'm,
I don't feel that people handle power.
They can't handle it.
You know,
that even goes for regular people,
a lot of people shit on,
you know,
the rich,
uh,
they're fucking assholes and they act like they're better people.
But I mean,
if,
if you just look it out,
what the people,
what people do on the Internet when they just have the power of being anonymous,
how fucking mean that they are.
And you know,
I know some people just trolling,
but a lot of people that just,
you know,
they're assholes.
They're like,
Holy Shit,
I can say whatever I want and not get in trouble for it.
And they just immediately just say the mean is shit they can possibly say.
You know,
I,
I think that
if you actually got a position of power where you could do something else,
you,
you'd probably abuse that too.
So anyways,
how,
how do I think they're going to take us all out?
I don't know.
I uh,
cell phones,
it probably just cooking our brains.
I have no idea.
I would think that they would do the usual shit divide
divide.
You,
you,
you basically
say that these people are better than these people.
These people are out to get us,
Yada,
Yada.
I Dunno,
but you know,
it has to be done.
People.
Do you think we're just going to keep having more and more people and eventually
the shit isn't going to hit the fan?
Do you honestly think the debt can be 7 billion people on the planet?
We're not affecting the planet.
You know?
Imagine if there was 7 billion deer on this planet and for some fucked up reason
for like a four year period,
they all really got into roller blading.
Did I use this analogy yet?
I can't remember.
Let's just say they all really got into roller blading.
Then I have to four years it was considered gay and they all got,
they just throw out their roller blades,
throw them into the fucking ocean.
I mean,
it would just be open season on deer.
They're like these fucking dare though.
Biggest assholes ever.
MMM.
Yeah.
We're out of control.
Brought control and a lot of tough are going to have to be made.
And uh,
I get,
I don't know what to tell you.
I find though,
I find it all funny though.
Um,
I've gotten beyond the scary scariness of it.
I got beyond the depression of it and uh,
something's going to happen.
Look,
if they're not actually,
look,
if somebody isn't out there trying to take over the whole world,
then humanity has been wiped off the planet.
There's always going to be somebody out there trying to do that shit.
But,
uh,
I don't know.
I think if we keep fucking and having kids and all that type of Shit,
uh,
I don't think we're going to have to worry about the new world order doing
anything to us.
I think mother nature will swiftly or slowly,
I dunno.
Well,
I handle it.
There's only so many fish.
Yeah.
You want to kill all of them there.
See how that works out.
You know,
melt the fucking ice caps.
Drown us.
Very easy.
Very easy to get rid of us.
Okay.
Couple of storms.
Do I sound crazy?
Well,
maybe I am.
And don't give a fuck a cheetah or at the Wilbur.
Um,
hey bill,
I saw,
uh,
I was at your late show last night and four again into a buddy that had a great
time.
All right.
Anyway,
about 20 to 30 minutes before the sensation,
Joe de Rosa took the stage.
By the way,
Joe Rose's taping his half hour comedy central presents right here in Boston on
Tuesday night.
And uh,
comedy central.
They given out free tickets.
So why don't you guys go down and support my boy.
I'd really appreciate it if you're busy.
I understand.
A couple of years.
Show up,
be a nice thing.
Um,
anyways,
about 20 to 30 minutes before the sensation took the stage.
He was great.
By the way.
I was sitting next to this fairly attractive woman
up in the mezzanine.
She took one look at this usher and you could tell her twat got wet and she
wanted him.
Okay,
Jason's still,
you were really paying attention to this.
Um,
she started talking to him and hitting on him and eventually settling on a time
and day to get together with them and they exchange phone numbers for about five
minutes after this exchange.
I was admittedly a little jealous of this guy until the Lady's husband came and
sat down with her.
He was definitely her husband.
And at first it was a little uncomfortable for me,
especially when she gave me,
uh,
you better keep your mouth shut or I'll stab you.
Look though this really happened.
Or did you train this?
Who would just fucking openly cheat?
Like,
I don't know if I believe this,
but after a couple of minutes,
I saw the irony of it when I thought she's here to see bill burr a who is famous
for his anger towards these whores.
And I started dying laughing right in the middle of the theater when it wasn't
even half full yet,
which got me a couple of stares from people that hell,
I thought it was fucking hilarious.
And this woman had no clue what I was laughing at,
which made it even better and I started laughing harder.
Anyway,
love the podcast and I will see you again at Hampton soon.
Um,
yeah,
look,
I hope that then,
I hope the way you were reading that it didn't go down that way,
but uh,
you know,
I bet on the road a long time,
boys and girls and that little Robert Dinero,
it looks easy to fall asleep.
MMM.
I've been on the road a long time and uh,
yeah,
I you,
you'd be amazed out married women behave.
It's fucking ridiculous.
And you know,
and it's not all of them.
Basically what it is,
the decent people after the show,
they go home.
You know why?
Because they're happy with their lives.
They're happy with who they're with.
They got kids,
they got a job,
they want to get back to their life.
It's the people who hang out afterwards unless she younger than your 20s.
But I'm saying
people who are married and they still fucking hang out.
This still searching.
There's still seeking,
you know,
and a shit happens.
People Alba,
God is Meryl Streep.
That fucking old.
Ah,
you know what?
I'm going to shut this off.
I can't fucking watch this shit anymore.
She looks like I can not to say that it's to me.
Can you say a first lady?
She looks like our first lady.
Uh,
did she get,
by the way,
does she get nominated every year?
She has to go down.
Like people always talking about like Deniro,
Pachino,
Marlon Brando and that type of thing.
You've got to throw her in there.
She's got to have the most nominations have,
Huh?
MMM.
Isn't that unbelievable email?
It's just,
let's just play along with this thing here and let's just say that that's true.
Like how long was this guy gone for?
Man,
it had been free.
She takes one look at this guy starts shooting the shit and they're talking loud
enough that you hear it and they exchange phone numbers.
I Dunno.
Well,
I mean,
I've,
I've seen,
uh,
I've seen worse.
Thanks.
I've been one time,
uh,
I was on the road,
you know,
drinking with some people afterwards.
There was this married couple
and the fucking wife in the end,
we all go to say goodnight,
say goodnight.
The husband,
she comes up and I'm standing there and she basically puts a clam on my fucking
leg,
just like walks right into it.
It was,
it was,
you know,
it was just like,
your husband's right over there.
You get your goods on my leg,
what are you doing?
And I'd like to tell you that that only happened one fucking time.
You know,
the deal,
women are smart with that dark.
I keep it in house.
I think they just talk about it amongst themselves.
But,
uh,
and then they got that great thing that even when they cheat,
it's,
it's always cause the,
oh,
the guy wasn't,
uh,
wasn't giving me what I needed,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
that's why guys cheat too.
You know,
you weren't bringing another woman into the bedroom so I could have a threesome.
Yeah,
no,
I don't fucking know.
Eight I'll be fucking unreal is what if your wife was one of those UFC checks?
You know when you're just a regular shit head like me,
what do you do when you catch a cheating?
What are you going to do?
That'd be fucked,
right?
If she goes,
yeah,
what are you gonna do about it?
She sort of cracks her neck.
You know,
you'd still have to take a run at her.
I swear to God,
I would grab a fucking the leg of a table,
you know?
That's what I,
that's that would be what I would do.
I would,
I would grab a blunt object and just swing below the waist.
You know,
cause that's a lesser degree of assault at a,
I just know that she has a,
she hasn't any of her training.
I know she can choke me out.
I know she can put me in an arm bar.
I know she's good standing up,
you know,
but she hasn't dealt with weapons.
I said I just start throwing shit at them.
Start with a chair or your clock plucks a great thing to have.
I guess if that's what that would be my fail safe.
If I married one of those UFC fight and chicks,
I would have a bunch of knickknacks that I've been slowly be accumulating acting
as though it was a hobby.
But it would,
it really would be is that would be stocking it with weaponry.
You know
what,
if she's an angry drunk,
comes home and just starts beating my ass.
Right.
And I got to fucking go to work the next day telling lies.
Yeah.
My name is Luca.
I married a UFC chick.
Fucking brutal.
Oh my God.
That'd be the end of your life.
You know what said there has to be a guy out there
who's just getting beat down by his woman every night.
There's just no,
you can't fucking bring it up to anybody,
you know.
Where's that fucking support group?
Um,
all right,
revenge.
Jesus Christ.
I am blowing through all these questions.
Revenge.
Uh,
Bill Barr,
I often have fantasies about getting people back,
but like you,
I look at my higher self and can't do it now.
That's not what I do.
I know I'm too fucking stupid and I'm going to caught,
you know,
and I've also watched enough sport sports where I know that the,
it's the guy who retaliates,
you know,
he's the guy always gets the penalty.
So anyways,
I got my revenge by living well and doing nothing.
Um,
here's what happened to at least a few of my enemies and he said I did nothing
to make this happen.
Okay?
So this guy is basically claiming that he always wanted to get revenge,
but he took the higher road and his revenge is living well and doing nothing.
So here's all these people that he wanted to fuck over but never did.
This is what happened to him.
The p these people,
all right,
first person I do who fucked with me eventually went to jail for buggery and
hanged himself when he was there.
What is buggery?
Is that fucking around Tom?
Is that Tom Foolery?
What country is this from?
Okay,
that's good.
How did you feel?
Good when he hung himself.
Uh,
another guy I hate was arrested for selling booze to kids and I laughed my ass
off when I saw him on a news story about a local ATF stink.
Oh,
that's a good one.
Uh,
another dude who fucked my lady and had the back of his head,
the back of his head caved in by an unknown assailant,
not me,
I swear,
because he buggered a child.
Okay.
All right dude.
If,
if any more people suffer is sort of the same violent ending.
I'm going to,
I'm going to start to think that I'm going to start asking where you were when
all this shit happened.
So anyways,
this guy goes to the back of his head,
caved in for fucking with the kid.
He's alive,
but is now retarded.
Uh,
you mean brain damaged?
you know,
I wish women would consider the possibility that they're hooking up with buggers
when they go out on a girl,
that they're girl power.
Fuck sprees.
Don't for the love of it.
God,
what is buggers me,
I got to look this up.
I can't read the rest of this shit.
What,
what,
what word am I looking up?
We look up buggery
the British term buggery.
Oh,
look at that.
Gotta love the Internet is a very close in the meeting to the term sodomy.
Jesus Christ,
and as often you,
there's a bunch of people in England laughing their ass off with me trying to
figure out what the fuck that was and is often used interchangeably in law and
popular speech.
It may also be a specific common law offense encompassing both sodomy and
beastiality
in English law.
Buggery was first used.
I don't give a fuck about that.
I don't care when it was first in 1533
Jason,
somebody probably fucked a Yak.
The hell do you fucking 1533 saber tooth tiger.
You could do that.
I think it would kill you.
Stick your Dick in a woolly mammoths trunk.
All right.
Defined punishments for the abominable crime of buggery committed with either
mankind or with an animal.
The definition of buggery was not specific in these are any statutes,
but rather established by judicial precedent.
Over the years.
The courts have defined buggery as including either anal intercourse by a man
with a man or a woman or vaginal anal intercourse by either a man or a woman
with an animal.
Well,
what if you fucking have anal intercourse with an animal?
Is that like some sort of a second degree?
Buggery
I don't fucking know,
but not any form of unnatural intercourse.
That is fucking unreal.
Okay.
Most common law jurisdictions have now been modified the lodge for knit permit
anal sex between consenting adults.
Jesus.
They have a picture here of a guy,
a depiction of buggery of a goat by the late.
Great Paul Avril.
Now I got this.
This is Wikipedia.
Now I got to look up Paul April.
Is this what he was known for?
Drawing.
Painting oil paintings of buggery.
Okay.
Evidently he was a French painter and a commercial artist.
All right.
Here's his gallery.
Got a couple of women.
Maybe it's a guy.
Everybody kind of looks the same and she's got her fucking legs spread.
Got To Jesus Christ.
This guy made some filthy fucking follow.
I see.
Holy Shit.
This guy has a photo of a guy banging a chicken is on her back while some other
dude is putting it in his ass.
I'll tell you right now that's not buggery.
He is.
He's committing it and have it done to them at the same time.
What the,
you know what
this is?
This is a,
I got a little,
this is really creepy.
Wow.
This guy really wrote pornographic shit.
Okay,
now there's a normal one guy and a girl.
here we go.
Who are you to say what's durable?
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
You know what I'm saying?
Mainstream.
He's got another one at two chicks.
One's going down on the other.
What the fuck year was this?
Isn't that funny how she always think that nobody did shit like the 1849 to 1928
so people are sitting there talking about the Internet and all this porn and how
hard it's going to do to you look at this shit.
This guy was paid to.
Okay.
Buggery everybody see that?
You learned something.
I like to think you learn something on every podcast and I have to go back here
for all the people here in America.
Okay.
And do to fuck with me.
Eventually went to jail for buggery and hanged himself when he was there.
Yeah,
cause he'll probably all screaming Chiton goat fucker at them.
Another guy I hate was arrested for selling booze to kids and I laughed my ass
off when I saw a news story about him at a Lopa ATF stick.
Another dude fucked with my lady at the back of his head,
caved in by an unknown assailant,
not me,
I swear,
because he buggered a child.
He fucked the kid.
Somebody came to his head and all right,
I liked that frontier justice.
He's alive,
but now he's brain damaged.
You know,
I wish women would consider the possibility that they're hooking up with buggers
when they go out on their girl power fucked sprees.
Now what do you mean by buggers now?
Does that mean that they're going out with a guy who would fuck a yak or fuck a
kid or going out with a guy who wants to put it in their ass?
Uh,
I don't,
you're losing me on this one.
Uh,
please,
please read this letter on your show in case any hose or listening.
Yuck.
I don't know what he's talking about.
My woman who fucked a child molester and it's become a 250 pound wart hog since
then.
So we're girl power days are over.
I got rid of her 15 years ago.
Thank God.
I don't know who to be.
Dude.
Use kinda sound just as bad as the people you,
I mean,
you haven't buggered anybody.
I hope what I made it kicks out just
you're definitely a,
yeah,
you're definitely a piece of work here buddy.
Uh,
yet another dude who used to pull the most bizarre mind games on me and others
coincidentally had an extremely expensive divorce.
I'm sorry,
I was just thinking of that fucking photo.
I couldn't get that out of my head that someone would actually consider doing
that back in the day.
It just seems like next level porno like that seems like the future,
not the past.
You know,
like a bunch of pornography people sitting around going,
all right,
what is left the doe?
Okay,
gay porn,
we already did that.
Heterosexual are dead.
That hey,
wait a minute.
You know,
all these djs are doing mashups.
I have an idea.
Um,
anyways.
Yet another dude who used to,
who used to pull the most bizarre mind games on me and others coincidentally had
an extremely expensive divorce.
Now he's poor and helpless.
Former boss who was a hot shot fuck,
went to jail for embezzlement.
Do,
what are you been doing?
How do you know all these people have gone to jail?
This person goes to jail for embezzlement.
This other kid fucks a kid.
Somebody buggered some.
I don't know what you know,
why don't you hang out with better people?
What part of the country do you live in,
sir?
Uh,
several other fuck head bosses who have lost their contacts or otherwise got
pushed into poverty or injury by various means.
You know,
this is starting to read like some fucking Charles Dickens story.
Is this shit really happening or is this your fantasies?
Uh,
many other bad things have happened to slap offs.
Who Hurt me?
And guess what?
I had to visit briefly with the police in a few cases because they learned that
I was a victim of the Douche bag.
Sorry,
I think this is just science fiction at this point,
but it's a good read.
I have a good reputation.
So I was never treated seriously as a suspect.
Many of these things took years before they came out,
but they happen nevertheless like clockwork.
I speak it very vaguely.
If anybody knows what's going on in this,
I have no idea.
All of a sudden I feel like I'm in some Sherlock Holmes Shit.
MMM.
Are you like Kevin Spacey and you're just making all this shit up and you're
going to walk out of the podcast and your club foot's going to straight.
Now
I had all the revenge I ever needed and never had to lift a finger.
Best of all,
my soul is intact.
I'm not dead and I'm not in jail.
The world has good things in store for all of us.
Your Monday morning podcast is great.
Thanks for cheering me up every week.
Every week.
All right,
sir.
That was,
uh,
definitely one of the more bizarre ones.
But you know something.
Thank you for writing in I,
Yah,
you taught me a new word and I saw a guy,
a new sexual position.
Anyways.
What the hell are we?
What the fuck do you go from buggery I should have closed on that.
Christ.
What the fuck is this?
Get this out of the way.
Um,
all right.
What do I do here?
I got to look another eight minutes to kill here.
MMM.
Women in UFC,
bas been at Boston.
I don't know what else to talk about.
I think that I might be a little short this week guys.
I really apologize about the unbelievably poor quality of recording these past
few weeks.
I've just,
I was really,
um,
I was really busy and I didn't get a fucking chance to,
uh,
to do something that would only take me fucking 20 minutes.
So was,
let's be honest.
But,
um,
I was really stressing about that Patrice thing.
I wanted to make sure that it,
it,
it went great.
And a,
this week on the weekend on stage,
I actually remembered to Patrice story that I told and I told you guys
eventually I'd be able to tell you a story.
MMM.
It's just sort of a rounder bub Patrice one,
but it's got Bobby Kelly did.
It's got him in it too.
I'll tell you this one and then I'm going to end this podcast.
Uh,
all right.
So
when I moved to New York,
I moved there.
Basically.
I had never lived on my own.
I went right from my parents' house to living in New York City.
I didn't know shit about the ladies,
right?
So I moved down to New York and I meet this girl who's an absolute fucking
psycho.
All right?
Like,
nowadays,
I swear to God,
I could talk to this girl for two seconds to realize that she was out of her
mind and I would not even,
I probably wouldn't even say hello to her.
They're just feet.
We'd some way,
the way our hours eyes were darting around the room.
I would know that she was out of her fucking mind.
But,
uh,
I was young,
I didn't know shit.
So
I ended up going out with her.
I need all the crazy girls.
They're fucking,
they're great in bed and when you're young,
you,
you keep coming back,
you keep coming back because you never,
you never had it like that before.
So I keep coming back.
But she was,
she was fucking nuts.
It was girl when she was crying.
I mean,
I,
I show up to her apartment,
she'd have like a fucking,
like a wig on and just act like she was somebody else that's fucking crazy.
And then,
you know,
fuck my brains out.
Like I'm,
I'm in my twenties I'm going to walk away from that.
We said,
I didn't realize that was what she sounded like she was out of her mind.
MMM.
So anyway,
so I finally just said,
listen,
this ain't working out,
will pop up,
blah,
blah blah.
And all of a sudden she turned into clean,
close in fatal attraction and I didn't know how to get rid of her.
She would like call me and one time,
like
she knew basically when I was going to be home and this is,
I didn't have an answer machine or anything like that.
Did I?
Yeah,
I think I did know I had voicemail and uh,
she'd fucking call and I'm laying in bed and I know what's her,
it's late at night.
None of my friends are going to call it nothing.
And uh,
and I just let,
let it go to voicemail and I swear to God,
eight seconds later she called again
and she was calling
like,
she did this for almost,
I swear to God,
like 40 minutes straight,
which is called my number.
It would go to,
she let it ring six times.
It would go to voicemail and then she would hang up and then sit there for five
seconds and then call me back.
And after like the fucking 400 times she did this,
I finally picked up the phone and I went,
what?
She says like,
Oh,
I just like want to talk to them.
I can you keep McAllen if a 40 minutes fucking straight.
I'm trying to go to sleep.
Right.
And I fucking hang up on her.
So she ends up coming by my apartment.
It's got,
it was out of a fucking [inaudible] she was out of,
I don't,
I just thought of her fucking mind.
So it just put,
keeps,
what I should have been doing is just,
I should just shut the phone off.
If you ever,
if you ever with like a psycho chick like this,
which you have to do is you just have to phrase them up.
You have to act like they don't exist because if you acknowledge them,
it just fuels them and they just keep fucking coming back.
So he finally told me that,
just say,
pick up the phone,
say hello.
If it's her,
just hang up on him.
Just keep doing that.
I,
but I didn't know to do that shit.
So this is so long gone.
I forget what happened.
All I know it escalates to the point that she is now threatening me and she told
me,
I'm living with Bobby Kelly by the way.
So he's given me advice.
He's also a young guy and he's also kind of laughing his ass off and we're both
kind of laughed.
And until one day she called me up and she threatened that she was going to stab
me,
do something violent to me,
really just freaked me out.
So I fucking hang up
and I'm going to Bobby.
I'm like,
dude,
what am I going to do?
You know I'm going down the cellar tonight.
I think I was at the comic strip and I'm like,
my fucking name.
He's right on the sheet.
She,
she's got to know exactly when I'm coming in.
Well what do I do?
He's like,
I don't know dude.
I fucking do you know where two coats or something matter of,
forget what the hell he told me to do.
So like two,
three hours goes by.
All of a sudden the apartment door buzzes and,
uh,
and it's her.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
hello?
She's like,
yeah,
it's me.
And I'm like,
yeah,
go fuck yourself.
And she goes,
no.
She goes like,
I want to give you something.
And I'm like,
what?
A fucking knife in the chest.
And she's like,
no,
I made your brownies.
I'm like,
what?
And then she went,
and from in three hours,
I'm going to stab you until I made you some Brownie.
So for some fucking dumb reason,
I buzzer it.
And,
uh,
I opened the door with the chain.
You don't standing way back behind it.
And that she is sitting there with their crazy,
yet those watery eyes that crazy people have big fucking deer eyes.
She goes,
can I come in?
I go,
absolutely not.
She goes to take the brownies I got.
I don't want it.
She goes,
take them.
She turns the fucking tin sideways and she pushes him through.
So I take,
and she goes,
I'll call you later.
And I said,
yeah,
okay.
Just trying to get rid of her.
All right.
Close the fucking door.
I set it down on the tape.
Me and Bob are a couple of starving artists.
They smelled delicious.
We're both sitting there staring at these things going,
what the fuck did we do here?
I want to eat them,
but she just threatened to fucking stab me.
What do we do?
So we call up the lake.
Great Patrice O'neil,
start telling the story.
He's fucking laughing his ass off and he goes,
don't eat those brownies.
That bitch probably peed in the batter.
Sit out the three of us a laugh from a fucking asses off like what do we do?
So long story short,
me and Bobby
ended up taking,
we take all the brownies out except for like three of them
and had we stick them back in the tin and we were living on the ground floor and
we brought it out.
We stuck it on top of a trash bag right on the sidewalk in anything you had on
New York City,
but you just stuck it out there.
We lived up on 97th street.
We had like crackheads living in like did the bowels of the building was fucking
nuts.
So anything you put out there was gone in two seconds.
So we just stuck it there.
We ran back into the apartment and we just sat there peeking through the
curtain,
wait for some homeless guy to come along and see what happens when you eat them.
Sure enough,
some homeless guy comes along,
he sees the 10 C's are men there.
Pick some squeezes them,
sees the fucking still warm pops one in his mouth.
Nothing happened being pop looked at each other.
We said,
fuck it.
We ate it and they were delicious.
Oh,
it with delicious.
That really wasn't a,
Patrice has only in the helium.
Made a cameo in that one.
But uh,
I'll try and tell some other ones later on.
But at Jesus belts,
you'll let us down on that one.
Did I?
It was a nice,
crazy woman's story.
Um,
it's fucking podcast.
It,
this is by Kryptonite.
If I don't have my recorder goes down by 20%.
And the funny,
anyways,
that was the Monday morning podcast for this week of Jesus.
Uh,
thank you for listening.
Um,
I don't know what shows I have coming up,
but I know you guys don't want to listen to me clicking on my computer anymore.
I,
I really apologize for the poor quality of these the last two weeks.
Uh,
I swear to God,
next week is going to be fucking crisp.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves and thank you to everybody here who came out to my shows at
the Wilbur theater.
It was unbelievable turnout.
Um,
every show was great and you know,
all my family and friends that came out,
people I went to school with and it was,
it was great to see everybody.
That is it.
I'll see the city of Boston.
I'll be back in this summer,
New Hampshire,
maybe down the cake.
All right,
that's it.
See Ya.